you've been a hostage negotiator for 10  years what was so special about this  case faced a hostage taker it's not like  working in a bank it's not like working  in an office people's lives are in your  hands you make a mistake someone dies  why don't you tell us something we don't  already know gee what do you want  whatever happened in the past you can  change something today do you realize  what you're asking you to do here yeah  we understand  we're dealing with a group powerful  enough the innocent covered up so damn  fast and police force the completely use  but these guys are planning we'll bring  the country to its knees no looking for  blood and done risking people lives I  will do whatever it takes you're not  alone in this house don't play games  with me  you